For the rest of the unit you'll be entering in routes. Let's get familiar with
how to enter these different types of roots using our awesome tool Math Quill.
To get the square root symbol we simply want to type a backslash and then the
letters sqrt for square route. When you type this you won't see anything quite
yet, you'll just see your backslash and the letters. You'll need to hit space
in order for the square root symbol to appear. You'll see this, and your cursor
bar will be underneath the radical symbol for you to type in whatever is
inside. And for this first one, you would want to type in a 2. But we haven't
just seen square roots. We've also seen cube roots. For a cube root or the nth
root, we simply want to type in a \ and then these letters. Then of course
we'll need to hit the Space. This will create a radical sign with our cursor
bar in the index position for the radical. Here our index is a 3, so we want to
type the number 3 to get that same index. Your cursor will still be in the
position of the index, so we need to hit the Right Arrow key once. To move it
back down underneath the radical, the cursor bar should appear here now and
were free to type in whatever expression is inside radical. In this case we
would just type x. Now see few have the hang of it. Try entering these two
expressions and using the keystrokes on the screen then try tackling these to
challenge problems. This one combines fractions, exponents, and radicals. And
be careful on this last one there's really a 4 for the index of this group.